I have watched tons of Dragonball facts
videos because I love me some Dragonball
but one thing I've noticed is a lot of
these while very well-made are not made
by Dragon Ball fans specifically and
thus leads to facts many might already
know which is annoying seeing as tons of
these videos post the title facts you
don't know but I did know these I did
times infinity screamed the comments
section and so because I love putting
myself under needless pressure for these
weekly video deadlines I ventured to the
far reaches of the internet to find 50
Dragon Ball super facts only the Wii
biasts of hardcore fans know and I'm
willing to bet even some that you don't
know yeah you I'm talking to you you
drinking out of your dragon ball super
mug while wearing your dragon ball super
PJs surrounded by Dragon Ball super
merchandise odds are that's a fact
inside here even you don't know so what
are we waiting for
let's dive straight into this ocean of
obscure Dragon Ball super trivia as we
list all 50 Dragon Ball super facts only
hardcore fans know Masako Nozawa has
been the Japanese voice of Goku for over
30 years but did you know that she has
two Guinness Book World Records to her
name that's right on October 25th 2016
she was certified as the voice actor who
voiced the same character in a video
game for the longest period and longest
video game voice acting career as of
December 14th 2017 her record stands at
24 years 8 months and 24 days we all
love next episode previews or hate them
if you hate spoilers but if you have a
keen eye you might notice differences
and mistakes in certain episodes any
piece this is due to these cuts or parts
of the next episode not being complete
yet infamously in the NEP for episode 6
Vegeta is seen with two left hands in a
lesser-known next episode preview for
episode 5 the symbol is missing from the
back of Goku ski both Vegeta's hands and
kakuzu ki were fixed in time for their
respective episodes airing longtime
Dragon Ball animator masa hiroshima new
ki after working on Dragon Ball Z went
to work on one piece during Dragon Ball
Z's inactivity in the late 90s and
2000's after years of working on one
piece he was asked to animate the
opening for 2005 Dragon Ball Z sagas you
can clearly tell that these designs are
distinctly one piece and not very
Dragonball
he's back to animating Dragonball the
way it's meant to be done Dragon Ball
super his Japanese voice actor for
Crillon may you meet Anika also voices
another popular anime protagonists in
one pieces monkey deal Luffy speaking of
the Japanese voice cast did you know
that the voice of Yamcha Toru Furuya
also voices daddy the father and Sabo
from one piece the original Japanese
voice of King Kai was Jo gu Nami
currently in his late 80s he has been
working on Dragon Balls since 1986 over
30 years ago he acted as the narrator
dr. briefs the king
dr. frappe King Kai and bobbidi
unfortunately he has recently fallen ill
giving up the role of King Kai to now
keep a cheetah
speaking of which now kita SATA is the
Japanese voice of oolong he also voices
Corrin
Ikaros bubbles Dragon Ball super
spaghetti and recently as I've told you
earlier King Kai speaking of King Kai
you know how Shawn chin will voices both
Goku and King Kai in the English dub of
Dragon Ball super
it's an unlikely hilarious pairing well
the French voice of Goku Patrick Borg
also voices majin buu in Dragon Ball
super smack-dab in the middle of the
resurrection F Ark comes episode 20
within which cruel ins phone begins to
ring fans of one piece will notice his
ringtone immediately it's an Opie for
one piece titled we are the animation
supervisor responsible for Episode five
got a really bad rap after the episode
got turned into a meme online but did
you know that he is also responsible for
this piece of animation produced for
episode 111 remember this scene from
Dragon Ball super well did you know that
this was the first time Goku and Gohan
fought since their training for the Cell
Games that's a long time ago
oftentimes phasma's complain and wonder
why Crillon doesn't use the ki an saan
after a solar flare see how I use the
English and the Japanese well in the new
fighter Z game that is one of his auto
combos and yes I'm totally counting that
as a Dragon Ball super video game
fighter z went to extreme efforts to
make the game look as though it was
ripped straight from the manga however
Goku's transformation into a Super
Saiyan might be familiar for another
reason
Shoni Schimmel publicly stated that he
wanted the US release of Resurrection
act to surpassed the 9.3 million dollar
box office that Dragonball Evolution
said however the film only managed 8.4
million
domestic toy animation and shueisha
wanted to create a new series like
Dragon Ball super as early as 2008
bought series creator Akira Toriyama at
that time wanted no part of it
did you know Dragon Ball super battle of
gods ark mostly takes place over the
course of an afternoon however this is
nothing compared to the majin buu work
of Dragon Ball Z whose seventy plus
episodes all took place over the course
of a day and a half speaking of Arc's
the resurrection F ark although having a
short three-part manga series
accompanying the movies release is not
part of the official Dragon Ball super
manga by Toyota row making it the first
Canon entry and the second ever saga
alongside the Garlic jr. saga from Z to
not be included in the official manga
the Future Trunks ark of Dragon Ball
super is the first arc in Dragonball
history to have the main antagonist
successfully complete their evil plan
while also losing but that's not all
this act also features the second time a
main arc antagonist was physically
killed by trunks the first being Frieza
sliced down the middle top-to-bottom and
Zuma soo sliced up the middle bottom to
top interestingly both side rows are
named after future trunks on April 1st
2017 toy animations website announced
the society survival R instead of the
universe survival work this naturally
was an April Fool's Day prank and the
poster advertising this coming Ark would
soon be changed back to its original
state while on the topic of the universe
survival ark did you know that the story
takes place in the Age 780 the same year
in which the alternate timelines future
Gohan dies while fighting the androids
in the original promotional material for
the universe survival Ark Geron was seen
to be the cloaked figure behind the god
of destruction for his respective
universe however there was a last-minute
change and when the episode eventually
arrived they had swapped out June 4 topo
the tournament of power is the first of
its kind in Dragonball being a battle
royale of sorts and as such is
considered one large fight making it
currently the longest fight in the
series history spanning 25 episodes as
of January 2018 the Japanese voice actor
for Geron aeg ha noah also voiced iron
man in marvel disk warriors the avengers
as of episode 92 in Dragon Ball super
Vegeta spent a little over
five years of his life in the hyperbolic
time chamber as of December 2017 the
heroes of Dragon Ball super have failed
to defeat every axe main antagonists
without the help of others
beerus defeated Goku only with the help
of Wiest did Frieza failed to destroy
the earth
Goku forfeits to his and the masu
succeeds in his mission having to be
destroyed by Zeno
youngja has not fought anyone in Dragon
Ball super but he has won a damn fine
baseball game in kaku's adult life
Dragon Ball super is the longest span of
time he is gone without dying currently
standing at over a hundred and twenty
episodes of life in a row and counting
well done Goku there are 12 gods of
destruction representing 12 separate
universes Akira Toriyama was responsible
for designing beerus Champa Katella and
Sidra while Toyota row design Moscow
Iraq the cure Ivan and Rahman the two of
them then collaborated to create gin
vermouth and helis according to an
interview Akira Toriyama was the one who
proposed the idea that turned the movies
battle of gods and resurrection F into
Ark's for Dragon Ball super stating that
the characters beers and we sweren Tegra
2 the plot of the series and fans needed
to know who they were the character
Menaka introduced during the universe
six are his voice by the same gentleman
who voices Ben load that got a
destruction Masami Kikuchi he is also
the voice of dr. rota who is from
universe 6 goku is currently 40 years of
age as of the tournament of power in
Dragon Ball super spending 8 years dead
total in the series and 4 years in the
hyperbolic time chamber trunks and
Dragon Ball super has an inconsistent
height within the show's established
Canon the tournament of power takes
place in the year 780 putting it right
at the same time the history of trunks
takes place meaning at the very least
trunks should be taller that he is
currently demonstrated as being the
character kami Cyrus of universe 4 as
seen or not seen as at or in episode 119
of Dragon Ball super hot his design
changed from what it was initially
announced as in an issue of jump
initially he looked like an insect
almost identical to diamond however
leading up to his episode debut his
design was changed to look more like a
chameleon did you know that during the
Future Trunks
arc Future Trunks is 30 years old on
November 6 2016 towards the end of the
Future Trunks arc Dragon Ball super
surpassed Dragon Ball GT in episode
numbers
assuming Dragon Ball super tournament of
power lasts into February the series
will have around 30 percent of its
episodes within a tournament Dragon Ball
super had an hour-long special in
October of 2017 airing episodes 110 and
111 in succession these two episodes
cause crunchyroll to crash numerous
times due to high traffic flocking to
the site to bear witness to Goku vs.
jiren which was a pretty damn good fight
prior to the tournament of Power Boat
amo Bergamo and a few thugs are the only
enemies Goku had defeated in Super
without help in episode 71 of Dragon
Ball super Goku is hit by bull Moz caps
all over you while carrying a giant fish
this is a callback to episode 1 of
Dragon Ball where the exact same thing
happens did you know occasionally
artists within toy animation will sell
their storyboards and other elements of
the production for Dragon Ball super on
Japanese auction websites for instance
anime AJ another youtuber you should
definitely check out purchased a
storyboard for episode 16 and he's very
fond of it Kiyoshi Hikawa sings the
second intro theme for Dragon Ball super
entitled Limit Break ex survivor but did
you know he also appeared before episode
115 as a character addressing the viewer
before the episode Dragon Ball super as
manga is there to promote the anime
while demanda is significantly further
behind to the anime in terms of story
progression potaro and his manga are
apparently much farther ahead of the
anime than we think fans saw this in the
first teaser trailer leading up to the
universe survival arc instead of
animation we saw Toyo Taro's manga
panels
despite at the time the manga only being
on chapter 19 covering the early stages
of the Future Trunks arc Dragon Ball
super is in the process of covering its
fifth arc as of December 2017 if you
were to look at 119 of Dragon Ball Z
that would bring you to the episode
where trunks awaits Goku's return after
his battle with Frieza meaning Dragon
Ball super covers more arcs in less time
as much as the Kira Toriyama loves
vehicles and his characters driving them
Toriyama has only drawn Goku driving as
a kid in the manga once and only briefly
apart from the covers and manga chapters
and volumes
Goku has only appeared driving as an
adult while in the anime that is until
Dragon Ball super manga illustrated by
Toyota Row where we see him drive
multiple times throughout as of
one-twenty Dragon Ball super tournament
of Power has become the longest
tournament in series history with no
ending in sight Goku is featured in
every episode of Dragon Ball super
except for - episode 7 and episode 73
and that's 50 this was my best attempt
at making a version of these videos for
fans of Dragon Ball super I really tried
to grab as much trivia as I could from
the series I even ended up rewatching
chunks of the series to fact-check
anyways I hope at the very least you
found this entertaining as always
comments and rings are very much
appreciated and if you would like to see
more Dragon Ball super analysis top tens
or whatever this was then feel free to
subscribe I upload every week and who
knows what next week's video will be
even I don't know or do i but that will
do it for this video thank you so much
for watching